i'm gonna first start by saying
how much i enjoyed wrath of man um i'm
very happy that you and guy
are back in a relationship um and uh you
know dating again
it's great i think fans are going to be
very very happy
uh yeah dating again i'm sure he'd be
concerned if perhaps if i told him
no we uh it's been quite a while you
know
it's been i'm trying to guess probably
15 years
since we last worked together and we
have both been on our little
journeys of you know up and down in the
movie business and uh
yeah it was about time we did something
together in fact oh you know i've been
knocking on his door
several times for different movies and
uh it just doesn't work out so this was
a
this was really you know a special
moment for us
uh especially to do something that we
were both sort of keen
and interested in doing completely i
have a ton of questions on wrath of man
but
during the pandemic during these virtual
interviews i ask everyone the same first
few questions
uh and so let's start with those uh
which is what tv series would you love
to guest star on
you know what i think i i have not
watched hardly any tv
since we've uh had a little kid i have
got no time in the day
or evening for anything so sure let's
jump to the next one it's not a problem
what movie or movies do you think you've
seen the most
what movies i've seen butch cassidy in
the sundance kid
numerous times cool and luke they're
probably about the uh
the most watched of my you know 50 years
of being around
um when do you obviously you've had a
listen you've had a great run for
um since guy started putting you in
movies um but i'm curious when did you
feel like
you made it as an actor like you can do
this and you can pay your rent
um i guess the second time i was hired
i mean the first time is is pure
guesswork and you don't know if it's
ever going to happen again and i was
quite content with the fact that i was
in
one movie uh and it was actually a good
movie
uh but you know you get hired again and
you go maybe i can do this
uh and i think there then it kind of
unrolls
in front of you that you you know you
are hireable and people
will go and see your ugly face one of
the things that i'm desperate for and i
know you've talked about it in the past
is what will it take for stunt
performers to be recognized
at the oscars and i'm just curious what
you what your
take is on that have you come around to
what what are you thinking about this
i mean i've always been a uh a massive
sort of uh advocate for the stunt
community because i think they are
they're so skilled and there's they they
are putting their lives at risk many
many times
in to make other people look great uh
and i think
what they're you know they train so hard
they put hours and hours and
they devote their lives to what they do
their skill set
uh and they are you know extremely
gifted human beings and they have
great uh ability to you know
disassociate themselves with fear and
they have to get the job done
they're just they're a unique set of
human beings and i think
their skill set is to be recognized
because not anyone can do what they do
and they
spend their lives honing their skills uh
and you know their their stuff is
featured
uh as much as anybody else has done you
know they're they are
in the world of an act you know in
marvel movies and
and action movies in general they are
the feature
you know it's all about the action uh
and i think you know it's
uh it's about time that they did get
some serious recognition
i i 100 agree and i really hope this
happens
um before i jump into rather man my last
other thing is i spoke to you for the
meg
you know how much i had so much fun with
that movie are you doing the sequel are
you involved in that
yeah we are we're going to start
shooting in january
uh if i get my dates right um
uh and ben wheatley is the director uh
i'm very excited to work with him
um um i'm thrilled to to get going you
know it's been a while
uh we've been waiting around for the
right sprints to come in and
the right director to turn up and we've
got all those things and they're all
stacked up now
yeah i spoke to ben recently for uh in
the earth and i told him
when i heard his name i was like are you
effing kidding me i can't wait
he's such a such an unusual and good
choice
yeah he's great we just we have a great
uh
a great short hand already you know
we've got we we've got cinematics
i like i like his movies i think he's a
brilliant director i think
uh i think we've got a good shot at
making something good jumping into wrath
of man
um one of the things i think is so good
about this movie is that it breaks with
the typical
narrative structure in like later in the
movie you have you're introducing a
whole bunch of characters
that have not been seen before it's
jumping around with time
can you sort of talk about your reaction
to the script because i think it's
really good
yeah uh it's you know it's it's really a
it's seen from three different
perspectives you know and i think it's
the
it's that we play when the movie kind of
you get to see
that one incident that kind of unwraps
itself
from three different angles uh three
different points of view from the
different characters involved
in that incident uh and i think it's a
really intelligent
script uh and i think it keeps you sort
of guessing
all the way through and you get to enjoy
this
you know uh this it's almost like a
combination of two movies like a heist
movie
and a revenge movie uh but you get all
of the you know the deep
the deep sort of uh drive from a guy who
is
just set on this uh this
spiral of you know trying to figure out
who's responsible for the death of his
son and it's a
it's a really gritty dark film uh
that it's not typical a guy guy's filmed
you know he's
he's definitely into his sort of black
comedy
uh and this is a little bit sort of more
serious in its tone which is
it's great but he what he does he
injects so much of his own
sort of style and the way that the
camera moves
and he gets to emphasize these moments
with
you know the right speed of the camera
drag and the
the score it's all it's it's a you know
he's such a talented filmmaker
i think the other reason why the film is
so good is
you we're surrounded by this great
supporting cast i mean i love
holt and you have a lot of scenes with
holt there's just it's a great cast can
you sort of talk about
um all these other people that guys
surrounded you with
yeah i mean that's a an actor's sort of
uh comfort
is to find you know great talent to be
around and you'd sort of uh
they bring their their a game and it
just helps you drags you along you know
holt was a real pleasure to work with he
plays this
super likable uh you know head of the
security company and he he's he's just
got some
he's just got this real panache about
himself
uh you know we've got some great actors
that i've had the pleasure of working
with in the past you know
uh eddie marzan is one of my favorite
actors scott eastwood i've worked with a
couple of times on the fast movies
he plays a great role um
uh you know jeffrey donovan i mean it's
a stellar cast it really is
yeah completely oh can you talk a little
bit about the way you and guy wanted to
craft action in this movie because
it's not the slicked choreographed kind
of stuff
that you've done sometimes in the past
it's a little bit more gritty and
real in my opinion yeah um
you know we spoke about this at length
uh you know i do action
and i i've done many many fight
sequences and set pieces and you know
you have to be careful that we don't
drift into that world
you know guy wanted to make a movie that
wasn't
a movie that i'd done before in terms of
the action he didn't want the fancy
tony kicks or he didn't want pre
had a pre-rehearsed choreography he just
didn't want it he wanted to have a
really different approach
an organic approach where you turn up on
the day you look at the situation
and you figure out uh what would really
happen
in this location you know the set
designers would build it and we'd turn
up
and you know usually you know typically
it's done
in advance uh you know weeks before and
you can figure out what stunts you want
to do
uh and do we need you know walls to
explode
it's it's uh it's a very unusual
approach and you have to be very
trusting in the in the director uh but
you know guys are really
he's a tough dude that know that
understands
fighting real fighting you mean he's a
great martial artist himself
and he understands visceral action and
he knows what
is is tough and he knows what isn't uh
so you're in really good hands he's a
he's a
an incredible sort of athlete himself
and he knows
you know he knows what where to hit
someone and if that would hurt
or not so you know anyway the approach
was to just
turn up on the day and figure it out
like a workshop almost
uh you guys after making this partnered
up again and just
i think wrapped on another movie
together um
so how did that sort of come about were
you making wrath a man and being like
[ __ ] it let's do another one
pretty much yeah yeah that's exactly how
it happened
it was uh you know we said this is
pretty much fun it was quite a sad sort
of day when we say that
when it was you know everyone was sort
of wrapping the movie and we said
we could do it another few weeks we
really could
so uh we said better than a few weeks
why don't we just do another movie he
said yeah leave it with me
and uh you know it it just came very
quickly so i've got this other thing
uh it's not much of a script at the
moment
um and i you know it was it's just an
impossible
thing that you say no to so we we were
you know
setting that thing up you know it wasn't
for the pandemic we'd have got a lot
we'd have gone a lot sooner you know six
nine months earlier
than uh we we ended up doing i have so
many questions about the follow-up but
i have to ask you before i run out of
time what is the story with the hobbs
and shaw sequel
how have how have you guys not started
making this
i have no idea i don't know
um we just sort of uh we sit around and
wait
for someone to go that you know it's a
big expensive movie remember that
i mean hundreds of millions of dollars
get spent on making the movie and
promoting the movie so
they have to have a good script uh and
you know we're we're we're motivated to
do something about that we're we're just
waiting for the right
we're waiting for the knock on the door
essentially uh
i got it do you think that um shaw will
make an appearance
in the final two fast and furious movies
um you want me to tell you yeah i mean
i don't want to get you in trouble but i
do want to know i'd love to come back
for those
you know a couple of movies uh it's very
it's
it's thin ice that i'm skating on if i
talk about
you know what's going to happen in the
next movies but uh
you know i know justin justin lynn i've
known really well
and we know it was funny when i came on
to do the
uh the cameo in part six
uh he never turned up to seven and eight
and they're the ones that i did so
we're destined to do you know something
bigger uh and you know
you know it's great to work within and
all the other characters i've made some
great friends on that movie and uh
i really love the film franchise itself
i think it's a global
success for all the right reasons you
know to be a part of it is just a great
privilege so if they uh
if they want me in the next ones i'll be
there but
god now i understand okay i'm gonna jump
back because i am curious about guys
next movie with you
um how would you compare it to wrath of
man
is it more of his earlier work where
it's like fun
and funny comedic moments or is it
another serious kind of film like
wrath of men no it's not a dog sort of a
revenge movie at all it's um something
much more
upbeat and funny uh but it has great
action and it's uh
it's it's uh i'm not going to tell you
too much about the plot because this is
the wrong
junket to say the tone of the movie is
definitely different
the tone of the movie is a much lighter
more comedic
affair um yeah it's back to more what he
does traditionally
yeah i have to rap i'm just going to say
it's always a pleasure to talk to you
you know how much
i'm a huge fan good luck with the rest
of your speed dating today
thank you